cet homme n'est pas le professeur
bretzel il y a 40 ans le 3 mars 1983
Georges Rémy alias Hergé s'éteignait à
l'âge de 75 ans son plus grand succès
Les Aventures de Tintin ont été vendus
après de 260 millions d'exemplaires et
traduites dans plus de 130 langues
Tristan de mers a écrit Tintin Québec
sur le passage d'Hergé dans la Belle
Province et sur son influence sur les
gens d'ici on avait besoin je pense de
s'identifier ou de passer par Tintin
pour créer au monde entier qu'on
existait c'est dans les années 60 c'est
l'éveil national il y a une conjoncture
sociopolitique aussi et qui fait en
sorte que Tintin est devenu le héros de
toute une génération souvent célébrée le
créateur belge c'est par contre fait
reprocher à l'occasion des penchants
racistes et antisémites une vision qui a
évolué au fil des albums on est passé
par une guerre mondiale on se termine ça
avec une ouverture à leur contemporain
on est vraiment ailleurs c'est pour ça
que c'est important pas préserver comme
une photographie à la limite en ajoutant
peut-être un contexte en première page
mais pour moi c'est une photographie de
ce qu'on a été avec ses forces et ses
aberrations
de s'adresser depuis Bruxelles à Denis
there Montréal en 1967 Jenny terrien
avait 13 ans il a remporté le Grand Prix
à l'émission Tous pour un sur Tintin une
expérience qui lui a permis d'obtenir
une bourse d'études et aussi de
rencontrer Hergé c'est un homme généreux
c'est un homme chaleureux
comme n'importe quel être humain
j'imagine qu'il y avait des erreurs et
puis
on peut on peut les relever maintenant
mais je pense que c'est aussi évident
que à 65 ans à peu près quand moi je
l'ai rencontré il pensait pas la même
chose qui passait à 20 ans
[Musique]
malgré le temps qui passe l'intérêt pour
l'oeuvre d'Hergé ne se dément pas il
s'écoule chaque année 4 millions
d'exemplaires de ses œuvres partout dans
le monde on en parle encore de Tintin 40
ans après la mort d'Hergé il va éteindre
s'entendre en 5 ans d'ici là et puis je
pense qu'on n'a pas fini d'en entendre
parler je m'appelle voici le capitaine
Haddock ici Nabil Alexandre Chartier
Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]